Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk about the unfortunate
fortunate situation of computer animation in
video games. Now I hear you asking, Doctor,
what do you mean by unfortunate fortunate?
Well, let’s start with the unfortunate part.
If we have created a beautiful virtual world,
and we have populated it with a bunch
of characters, we now wish to see the
two interact. And therein lies the problem. With
previous techniques, either the quality of motion
is lacking, or generality. In other words, if the
motions are of high quality, they don’t transfer
to new scenes, or if they do transfer to new
scenes, they are typically not high quality.
So that is the unfortunate situation. Now
what about the fortunate part? What is so
fortunate? Well, I feel very fortunate
today. Get this. I seem to be the fourth
person to have read this paper. And I am
very excited to say that I think I have
found a little gem to share with you that might
just solve the problem we have at hand. Look.
This one builds on top of the Adversarial Motion
Priors (AMP) paper from SIGGRAPH 2021. This paper
could place a virtual character in a virtual
environment, and it looked at a dataset of real
clips of movements like running, jumping and
rolling, and even punching, and it was able to
learn to use those motions in these video game
worlds to its advantage to finish a level. Now,
what about this new technique? Does it do what
we really want to it to do? Yes, yes it does!
Fantastic. It builds on top of this AMP technique
and generalizes it so that these characters
will not just run around in the scene, but it
teaches them to interact with the scene as well.
So what does this mean? Why is
this new? Well, because one,
this is finally able to create motions that
are both high quality as the one you can see
here as it is encouraged to solve these tasks
with style. And two, this one also generalizes
to new objects and environments at
the same time. An absolute miracle.
This was trained with a lot
of different object types,
orientations and locations. And when I
say that they can do this with style,
I mean that they can do this with style. Look
at this jolly chap. He is fabulous. Love it.
And these objects are newly designed objects that
the AI hasn’t seen yet. And it can still use them
just fine. High-quality motion is being created
in a way that finally generalizes. So good!
And this AI has undergone strict testing,
and the scientists found that we can put
any kind of box anywhere, this little AI
will be able to bring it back. I also love
this scene which shows a variety of different
motions for walking towards this object and
sitting on it. If only they have made
a musical chairs version of it where
one of these poor little characters will be
eliminated each round. May the best AI win!
And, are you thinking what I am thinking? Do
you know what is coming up now? Of course,
testing against external perturbations. Oh
yes, the favorite pastime of the computer
graphics researcher. Look. These folks are
not only robust, but super patient as well.
Look at these nasty tricks the scientists
tried to pull on them. Not a single one
worked. So good! Loving it! Look…whoop!
Whoop! Alright, you get to sit down now.
Whoop! Sorry, I had to. Okay, you can sit
now. Good job! A+ for patience, little AI!
Now, not even this technique is perfect,
the success rates are not a hundred percent,
but it is typically above 90% and I
am fairly sure this can be improved
or at the very least be filtered in a way
that it approaches nearly a 100% for real
applications. If we start messing with them,
like throwing boxes at them or tripping them up,
this success rate falls by about 3 to 10%.
That is very respectable, especially given
by how badly we have treated them. Sorry about
that. But we got to proceed with the testing.
So, in a new paper that only 4 people had
seen yet, we finally get this age-old problem
in computer animation solved. I can’t
believe it. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!